I Wanna Be the fair that thing love that
is the worst don't you dare that whole
Pokemon CD makes me want to jump out of
a wi oh I just love the the the
theme song the intro the worst song of
all time disagree it infuriates me to
hear it I'm I can't wait to I'm going to
change that to my ringtone and wake you
up on the road from now on with Pokemon
dude oh my God I'm I got to write that
down so I remember the absolute maybe
it's because it just brings me back to
having to listen to that CD can
I tell you what that CD did the good
thing it did it
officially when we got done playing it
when you guys because you guys probably
played it 8,000
times when you guys got done playing
that I officially changed the rules in
the car